so I've tried TV and I try it and it
doesn't work and then I go back to
comedy and then if something I'm doing
is the stand-up leads me back to like
hey this might be a show then I'll try
I'll try anything that I think might be
good I don't care about like well I
failed at it before you know what I mean
who cares try it again I mean I love
that flatfish well awesome you were this
time I did a pilot the very first time I
got a deal to do a pilot for a sitcom
yeah I wrote it and they really liked it
and it got close and then they said
we're not gonna make the pot we got to
shoot a pilot was so excited and I shot
a pilot and then they said we're not
gonna make the show all right third time
around made a pilot and got one season
of lucky Louie on the air and then
that's all they wanted I did one season
okay and now I'd done Louie and it's
I've gone three seasons so I'm got a
little further each time I push the ball
a little further ahead each time I mean
not doing something because they don't
work would be like if you're a
quarterback and you go to the line of
scrimmage at the 25 or wherever the guy
ran it to and you hand the ball off and
the guy pushes it eight yards and you're
like well we don't score a touchdown
let's all go home right I mean there's
no point but at the same time 15,000
people laughing at your jokes that's a
it's kind of an amazing feeling but also
having them sit there looking at you
listening is really great too but I
always see I've done it three times now
and it was the same every time that
they're all laughing the show's going
great but what I see are there's at
least in 15,000 people is like a
thousand disappointed people there's
like a thousand people and they're
dotted I see them all I see him still
today but during the show
I see them just guys going like yeah
those are the ones that you really see
every day and I'm just sorry but the
more people you reach and the more
people that see you the more people are
gonna think that you suck that's just a
blog mathematics but let me please
everybody you just watched two amazing
clips from louis c.k take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]